we cannot continue to spend money we do
not have a passionate pitch for getting
a handle on federal spending by arguing
for a balanced budget amendment and the
joint resolution is not passed what the
house vote came up short 233 to 184 late
today shy of the two-thirds majority
needed unsustainable mandatory and
undisciplined discretionary spending
designed decades ago have created a debt
monster that is seemingly unstoppable
Democrats mocked the GOP for wanted to
show fiscal restraint after passing tax
cuts and approving more spending like
some Starmie sermon from Trump on the
virtues of chastity
I believe these House Republicans today
really do deserve a gold medal for
hypocrisy the House Democratic leader
hammered the GOP saying this push would
go nowhere now Republicans have the
hutzpah to bring forth a balanced budget
amendment engineered to force
devastating cuts to Medicare Medicaid
and Social Security the White House is
also pushing Congress on another fiscal
matter seeking to surgically remove at
least a small portion of the 1.3
trillion dollar spending package
president Trump signed last month
there's a lot of funding in the
government that we would all agree is is
wasteful and so I think there's several
things that that we will want Congress
to take a second look at
I think is the the president of the Ford
rescissions package in the near future
senior lawmakers in charge of spending
see that as reneging on a deal so it's
not entirely clear how much support that
will have but it would give fiscal Hawks
another opportunity to show they're
trying to do something about spending